Hallo, meine Sistema-Name ist die Assistenz der Erste auf der Desistation und ich würde gerne das Aufnahmegeschichte mit Ihnen führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Ja, ich würde gerne am Anfang ein paar allgemeine Fragen schließen. Dann können wir über ihre Beschwerden beschreiben.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Schmitz Renate.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Schmitz? Vorname?
Schmitz ist der Nachname.
Nachname.
S-T-H-D-T am Ende.
S-T-H-M-I-T-Z.
Schmitz.
T-T-Z.
Können Sie bitte auch Ihr Vornamen beschreiben?
R-E-N-A-T-E.
Renate.
Renate. Okay.
Okay, Schmitz.
Wie alt sind Sie?
40 Jahre alt.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ungefähr 69 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 Meter.
So, Frau Schmitz, was für Sie uns, was können Sie tun?
Also, ich habe seit Längerem schon Ödeme in den Beinen unten.
Ödeme in den Beinen.
Seit wann?
Sie sind geschwollen, also ungefähr seit 4 bis 5 Monaten schon.
Ja, Sie sind geschwollen.
Und ja, eigentlich bin ich gesund.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht jenen kommen, aber mein Mann hat mich geschickt.
Ich soll mich doch mal vorstellen bei Ihnen.
Ja, sind Ihre Beine geschwollen?
Sie sind beide geschwollen, ja.
Beide geschwollen.
Haben Sie irgendeine Farbe veranderen gemacht?
Ja, ich habe sie geschwollen.
Nein, wir sind gleich.
Wir sind gleich.
Gleich, Frau B.
Haben Sie Schmerzen an dieser Region?
Nein.
Rötung, Schmerzen.
Auch nicht.
Die schmieren sich schon schwer an.
Schwer an, okay.
Also, hat es Sie früher ähnliche Symptome?
Das erste Mal, also ich habe es vorher nicht gehabt.
Waren Sie schon einmal beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Für diese Beschwerden?
Nein.
Ich wollte auch nicht zum Arzt gehen, aber mein Mann hat mich geschickt.
Ja, ja.
Und er hat sich Sorgen gemacht, weil auch mein Recht ist Auge,
bisschen geschwollen ist.
Mein Recht ist Auge.
Ja, ist auch ein bisschen geschwollen, aber ich glaube, das geht weg.
Vielleicht habe ich auch nur eine Entzündung, ich weiß nicht.
Ist das allrot geworden?
Nein.
Oder Lügzes oder Halbis?
Frau Schmidt, wie sieht es beim Wasalas aus?
Ja, also.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasalas?
Wie sieht es bei Ihrem Verdauungssystem aus?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Ganz gut, ganz gut.
Ich kann alles essen.
Ich habe keine Unverträglichkeit und alles gut zu weichen.
Keine Blöden, keine Sorgen, Öbelkeit, Keine Spannung oder?
Okay.
Keine.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie Fieber in der Nacht?
Nein.
Nein, kein Fieber.
Oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Aha.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ganz gut eigentlich.
Haben Sie in der Saison abgenommen oder so genommen?
Nein, gleich gewesen.
Ich habe 1-2 kg Zugriff, aber ich glaube, deswegen in den Beinen.
Ja, kann sein.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie am Morgen oder am Abend mehr Ödem an Ihren Beinen haben?
Nein.
Aha.
Also, die sind seit 4 bis 5 Monaten immer so gleich.
Also, meine Mama hatte das auch für gehabt.
Und da dachte ich, wahrscheinlich ist das angeboren und hat mir nichts bei gedacht.
Ja, also.
Ist das eine Verbindung mit der Bewegung?
Nein.
Oder beim Aufstehen?
Langessheit aufstehen?
Nein.
Nein, okay.
Ja, wenn ich drauf drücke, tut das schon ein bisschen weh.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Schmerzmedikamente nehmen muss oder so was.
Okay.
Wie ist es mit Ihrem Alltag, wie ist es mit dem Beben, das man aufstehen kann?
Ja.
Langesstrecken laufen?
Aber es ist kein Problem.
Sie haben kein Problem.
Okay.
Können Sie flach liegen?
Ja, das können.
Aber ich habe keine Probleme mit.
Aha.
Wie viel ist es für Können Sie aufsteigen?
Ein Augenblick kurz, mein Akkus.
Können Sie die Frage nochmal wiederholen, bitte?
Ja.
Können Sie die Treppe aufsteigen?
Wie viel ist das für Können Sie aufsteigen?
Also habe ich jetzt nicht kontrolliert, aber ich habe keine Probleme damit.
Ich wurde im zweiten Geschoss in der Wohnung, ich habe ganz gut.
Ja, Sie haben kein Problem.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendetwas ausprobieren, um Ihre Ödemes zu linden oder vermindern?
Zum Beispiel Hochlagerung, Kühlen oder Wärmen?
Nein, das habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Ich mache hier das manchmal ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen Massage mache ich, aber das hilft nicht so.
Und ich glaube, das ist einfach genetisch bedingt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Meine Mama hat das auch.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Krönchen.
Nein.
Okay.
Wo sind Sie jetzt die Situationen behindert?
Nein.
Okay.
Sie haben wegen einem Infekt, weiß ich mal,
vor der Zeit, die Sie aufsteigen,
die Sie aufsteigen, die Sie aufsteigen,
haben Sie wegen einem Infekt, weiß ich mal,
vor drei Monaten oder vier Monaten war ich mal für einen Tag im Krankenhaus.
Ich habe einen sehr starken Infekt gehabt,
einen Grippe habe ich gehabt.
Grippe?
Aber nur einen Tag, weil ich da dann weiß,
wieder weggehabt.
Ja, dann Sie wurden entlassen.
Genau, und einen Tag haben Sie mich aufgenommen.
Das war bei einem anderen Krankenhaus.
Ja, okay.
Ist das eine Operation? Nein.
Nein, keine Operation.
Okay.
Gibt es Medikamente, die Sie regelmäßig einnehmen?
Nein, keine Medikamente.
Manchmal paratzt es amohl, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe,
oder manchmal auch Ibukofen, aber sonst
eigentlich nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Ja, wenn es sich umfällt, habe ich.
Genau.
Sind Sie bei Ihnen allergisch bekannt?
Hausstop.
Hausstop allergisch.
Ein Punkt, bitte.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie Öderm bei Ihren Augen haben.
Am welchen Auge.
Am rechten Auge.
Ja, seit zwei Tagen ungefähr.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Deswegen hat sich mein Mann Sorgen gemacht.
Ja.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie eine Farbeveränderung
in Ihrem Urin haben?
Nein.
Nein, keine Farbeveränderung.
Das gleich.
Also, es guckt auch nicht so drauf, ne?
Also, ich habe das nicht so beobachtet.
Okay.
Ja, ja, das ist ja schon recht.
Aber wenn etwas wäre, Sie würden das bestimmt bemerken.
Ich hoffe doch.
Ja, viel, ja.
Sind Sie gegen Corona?
Posteinlich?
Ja.
Dreimal sind Sie auch gebustet?
Ich bin auch gebustet, ja.
Ja.
Ich finde jetzt noch ein paar Informationen über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Rachen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich bin nicht mal, wenn wir in Gesellschaft sind.
Einmal in der Monat oder weniger.
Noch nicht mal.
Vielleicht alle beim Geburtstag oder Weihnachten zum Beispiel.
Oder wenn wir mit der Familie zusammen sind.
Darum trinke ich ein bisschen Wein oder Bier.
Aber ich bin keine Alkoholikerin.
Ja, nur so ein Bechtimtsin anlasse.
Okay, danke.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per Sony, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Nein.
Ja.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie keine Schmerzen an Beinen haben.
Visites auf...
Wenn ich drauf drücken, wenn ich drauf drücken, tut das schon weh.
Aber so habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Die sind halt nur schwer, die Beine.
Aber Schmerzen nur, wenn ich drauf drücken.
Wenn Sie drauf drücken, bleibt dort ein Loch?
Oder Druck?
Ja, doch so ein bisschen.
Das bleibt so in der Delle.
Delle, ja.
Dort bleibt eine Delle.
Kontest surrück wieder?
Ist es surrücklofund?
Ja.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche Krankheiten,
wichtige Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Also ich habe keine Geschwister.
Meine Mutter hatte Herzbeschwerden.
Sie hatte so Herzkammerflimmern oder so was.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt.
Irgendwie so Herzprobleme.
Und mein Vater hatte Blutdruck.
Blutdruck hatte er.
Hatte Papa gehabt und Mama hatte so Herzkammerflimmern oder so.
Die hatten auch geschwollene Beine gehabt.
Okay. Lebt Ihre Mutter noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, ja.
Vater?
Nicht mehr.
Schlaganfall.
Wie alt war er?
65.
Sie haben keine Geschwister.
Frau Schmidt, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Büro, Bürokaufbau.
Bleiben Sie das ganze Tag am Tisch?
Oder können Sie sich bewegen?
Ich bin hauptsächlich am Tisch.
Momentan bin ich auch so ein bisschen homeoffice.
Aber ich muss manchmal kopieren, manchmal auch Sachen wegbringen.
Ich bin froh, aber meistens bin ich am Scheibdich.
Okay.
Zwei Beinzehs-Sport?
Ich gehe mit dem Hund spazieren manchmal.
Jeden Tag oder einmal in der Woche?
Ja, jeden Tag muss ich zu Gast gehen mit ihm.
Aber mindestens ein bis zweimal.
In der Woche.
Manchmal macht das auch mal freundlich.
In der Woche ein, zwei Mal.
Am Tag?
Am Tag.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Stress am Arbeitsplatz?
Ja, wir haben momentan den Corona viel zu tun.
Aber der übliche Stress, den glaube ich jeder von uns hat.
Ja, das belastet uns nicht so viel.
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Wie ist die Familienstadt?
Ich bin lehrisch, aber ich habe ein Tatmutter mit dem Susann.
Dilebensusann, okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Frosch mit Wiesnien-Direperiode?
Normal, ich habe kein Problem.
Haben Sie Bauschmärzchen,
Oldeschmärzchen, Bayer-Vasvalaschen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay, dann Frosch mit, ich bin fertig mit meiner Frage.
Haben Sie noch Franken an mich oder möten Sie etwas ins Zufügen?
Ich muss zuerst körperlich unter den Zuhall.
Dann habe ich mich nicht zuerst in der Zufugung.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Ich bin nicht in den Zuhall.
Wiesnien-Direperiode, an der Zeituição vorYAN耀 Подlysne.
Good job,
topw飲der,
das braucht viel Zuschauer.
Das geht peut yummy.
wir wieder über ihre Situation besprechen. Okay. Okay. Ja, dann bitte nehmen Sie Platz
in Wartesima und ich komme zu Ihnen in fünf Minuten. Alles klar. Danke. Danke, tschüss.
Kann ich eine Frage stellen? Klar. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, ob Danachke fragt
wurde hat sich Ihre Gewicht in letzter Zeit merktlich verändert? Ja, ich habe mich nicht
gehoben, aber ich denke schon, dass ich so zwei drei Kilo vielleicht mehr wiege. Okay. Ich glaube,
dass ist vielleicht wegen den Beinen. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber sonst habe ich immer so ein stabiles
Gewicht. Habt ihr in letzter Zeit bemerkt, dass Sie Müdigkeit, Unruhe,
Schlafstörungen, Konzentration, Schwerheit haben? Ja, ich bin schon ein bisschen müde als sonst.
Das stimmt. Also ich bin müde auch tagsüber, bin ich müde. Haben Sie eine Kampferin?
Wenn Sie etwas lauter sprechen, ich höre Sie nicht. Haben Sie eine Kampferin an Ihrem Beinen?
Kampferin? Nee, nicht, dass ich das sehen kann. Haben Sie Atemnot oder Hüftung Sie?
Nein, ich wusste nicht. Sind Sie auf Ihren Augen lieb? Nein, ich bin nicht gefallen. Das ist plötzlich
gekommen, seit drei Tagen ungefähr. Sind Ihre Schwellungen an Ihrem Bein eher an Knochen oder
am Oberröhrregion Ihres Unterschenkels? Eher die unteren Schenkel, aber schon, ich würde sogar schon
sagen, die kommen so langsam hoch bis über das Knie, fast. Wann kommen Sie hoch, tagsüber oder
in Darnart oder wann sind Sie gleich? Gleich, immer gleich. Ja, ich glaube schon, ich kann das so
nicht einschätzen, aber nachts gucke ich ja nicht drauf, weil sich leider nicht, aber ja,
wir sind gleich eigentlich. Hätten Sie schon einen Wunder an Ihren Beinen? Nein.
Sollen wir als erstes Gespräch durchführen? Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit mir?
Jetzt werde ich Sie so als körperlich untersuchen, dann werde ich Ihnen das Brut abnehmen,
ja EKG schreiben lassen und werde ich Bauch Ultraschall dutschführen. Ich werde auch Ihre Lungen abführen,
ich werde das alles abführen.
Dann nach der Laboruntersuchung oder sobald alle auf dem Vorliegen,
werde ich mit meinem Chef ausbeischrechen und dann komme ich zu ihnen.
Dann können wir wieder besprechen ob sie hier bei uns bleiben müssen
oder nach Hause gehen können.
Okay?
Gerne.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eben gerade einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen
und ich würde gerne die Patientin Ihnen vorstellen.
Hätten Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, schießen Sie mal los.
Ja, danke.
Frau Schimitz ist eine 40-jährige Patientin.
Sie hat sich bei uns wegen seit vier bis fünf Monaten gestern
Beine in den Beinen vorgestellt hat.
Die Patientin hat berichtet, dass die Beine geschwollen sind.
Aber die Frage nach einer Farbepherränderung,
Kolor, Rüber, Dolor, Tümmer, wurden fein eingestellt.
Die Patientin hat berichtet, dass die...
Sie hat keine Schmerzen, wenn Sie drauf drücken oder so, ne?
Hat sie...
Netis oder lechimatschen, aber die Patientin geht,
weil sie ein bisschen Schmerzen hat.
Ja, okay.
Ja, und außerdem hat sie bemerkt, dass sie seit zwei Tagen
an ihrem seiten Rechtenauge organisch geschwollen hat.
Die Vegetativanamnes ergab keine Auffälligkeiten.
Sie hat kein Heba, sie hat kein Problem mit Fardalungssystem.
Sie hat mit ihr Schuttus oder Rinds.
Die Patientin hat nichts ausprobiert, um ihre Schmerzen
oder um ihre Ödemsullien.
Die Medikamentin an der Analyse ergab nur Parasitamol
und Ibuprofen-Einnahme bei Bedarf.
Sie hat nur allergie gegen Hausstopp, sie ist gegen Corona,
dreimal geimpft.
Sie wurde vor drei Monaten im Krankenhaus wegen Grippe behandelt,
aber sie hat nur im Krankenhaus einen Tag geblieben.
Als Gewohnheiten, sie ist keine Raucherin, sie trinkt Alkohol nur
auf bestimmte Anlassungen und die Fragen nach Drogenkontakt
wurden verneint.
In der Familienanalyse ist es erwähnt, dass ihre Mutter
eine Arterialpibrillation und Herzinstitut hat.
Ihr Vater hatte Arterialparten und ist an Apoplex gestorben.
Sie arbeitet in Büro als Bürokauffrau.
Sie ist nicht verheiratet, aber lebt mit ihrem Freund.
Sie hat keine Kinder.
Sie hat ein bisschen Bewegungsmangel im Arbeitsplatz,
aber sie läuft ein, zweimal in der Tag,
in der Tat zu sein mit ihrem Hund.
Die Frage nach Müdigkeit wurde bejaht.
Sie erwähnt, Abgeschleidenheit zu haben.
Das war die Frage und die Antwort,
die ich mit Ananas gesammelt habe.
Sehr gut.
Was haben Sie denn vor,
mit der Patientin, die aktuell schon eine Verdachtsdiagnose ist?
Mit dieser anhand angangs- ananas- tische
kann ich leider keine Hinweise bekommen.
Aber es gibt viele, die nicht in der Arbeit sind.
In der Arbeit sind die Ananas, die die Anklage
in der Tat zu haben.
Es gibt viele, die nicht in der Anklage sind.
Selbst auch, dass sie kein Problem mit Wasser lassen oder kein Problem mit Bewegung hat.
Warum glauben Sie, dass es eine Nierdienung so effizient sein könnte?
Weil sie die Beine als Augenlid hat.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Urinprobe bestimmen.
Was erwarten Sie, weil es in der Urinprobe etwas Nephrologisches sein sollte?
Ich würde das Protein im Urin probe bestimmen.
Das würden Sie erwarten?
Ja, ich würde das Protein erwarten.
Würden Sie etwas Blut erwarten?
Ich würde das Blut erwarten.
Das ist eine Dienste.
Es gibt eine Dienste, die sich in der Föhnung verwendet.
Es gibt eine Piafeka, die sich in der Föhnung verwendet.
Aber die Patienten bei der Herzinsuffizie sind Atemnot,
Atemnot und Müdigkeit, Abgeschlagenheit auch andere hinweisen.
Unsere Patienten hat keine diese Hinweisen.
Kann es nicht einfach auch ein Lymphödem sein?
Es kann sein, aber sie hat Lymphöde bei der Beine.
Deswegen, wenn es nur eine Beine wäre, würde ich auch Pafeka oder Lymphöde vermuten.
Aber beide Beine sind geschwollen.
Aber kann Lymphödem oder Lymphödem nicht ein Bein sein?
Wie können Sie das unterscheiden?
Ein Lymphödem, Lymphödem mit einem normalen Herzinsuffizie zum Beispiel.
Wie kann man das klinisch unterscheiden?
Das ist ganz einfach.
Nicht unterscheiden.
Sie müssen bei der Untersuchung immer darauf achten, die Udeme sind unterschiedlich.
Bei Lymphödem oder Lymphödem können Sie die gar nicht wegdrücken.
Bei einem normalen Udem können Sie die wegdrücken.
Es bleibt eine Delle, die sich dann wieder zurückentwickelt.
Also können Sie Lymphödem, Lymphödem ausschließen.
Sie haben recht. Sie haben keine Luftnoten, haben Sie erzählt.
Sie haben keine Belastungsdüsten.
Sie müssen sich schauen, ob sie vielleicht trotzdem Vorflimmern hat.
Unbemerktes Vorflimmern.
Sie müssen sich ausschließen in der KG.
Also, es kann, hat sie eine besondere Ernährung.
Ernährt sie sich irgendwie anders?
Hat sie vernachlässigst ihr irgendwas oder so?
Oder hat sie das davon erzählt?
Ja, sie hat Dorebani z.B. saved.
Sie hat aber kein Problem mit Dames.
Durchfall hat sie auch nicht.
Auch nicht verstopfen durch Fall.
Medikamente nimmt sie auch nicht ein.
Die hat auch nicht zu viel Ibuprofen genommen,
so dass sie in ihren Geschädigten sind oder so.
Dann können Sie ja eigentlich viele Sachen ausschließen.
Wenn Sie jetzt keine Vorflimmern hat,
dann hat sie wahrscheinlich keine Herzinsuffizienz.
Wie würden Sie das denn im Blut kontrollieren,
ob Sie eine Herzinsuffizienz hat?
Was würden Sie bestimmen?
Im Blut.
Ja, Sie haben jetzt ein EKG gemacht.
Und das EKG ist ein Sinusrückenmuss.
Normal, norme, frequent.
75 schläge pro Minute.
Wie können Sie im Blut ausschließen,
dass es ein Herzproblem ist?
Probe an P.
Ja, weiß, hat meist auch Herzinsuffizienz im Blut.
Genau, sehr gut.
Dann haben Sie ein Herzinsuffizienz ausgeschlossen.
Liebte Idee, dass Sie eine Herzinsuffizienz haben.
Liebte Idee, Blutidee, ist es auch nicht.
Kann es ein Infekt sein,
dass Sie hat durch ein Infekt bedingt, kann das sein?
Was würden Sie Blut kontrollieren?
Es kann auch erisipel sein,
aber Sie hatten keine Rötungen, also Infektzeichnen,
wie Kaloribber, Dolor, keine Infektzeichnen.
Was würden Sie Blut kontrollieren?
Anzündungsparameter, BSC und Serepä.
Ich würde in Blut kontrollieren.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ich komme gleich noch mal auf die Entzündungswerte zurück.
Gut, was würden Sie noch in Blut kontrollieren?
Ich frage jetzt mal gezielt.
Was würden Sie kontrollieren im Blut, speziell bei ihr?
Für diese Patientin.
Über meine Verdiagnose Nierenwerte, habe ich gesagt.
Würden Sie auch die Leberwerte kontrollieren?
Ja, ja.
Das kann ja sein, vielleicht hat ja die Leberzirose.
Dadurch die Odeome, kann auch sein.
Ja, kann auch sein.
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass die Leberwerte nicht vergessen.
Was sind denn die Leberwerte?
S G O T und S G P T können erhöht sein.
Ja, ganz genau.
Wenn Sie eine Synthesistürung der Leber kontrollieren möchten,
was kann man noch kontrollieren im Blut?
Ja, Albumin.
Albumin, gibt noch einen Wert, den kann man auch kontrollieren.
Auch noch etwas.
Die Schulinesterase, die können Sie auch kontrollieren.
Das zeigt eine Synthesistörung oder keine Synthesistörung.
Wichtig bei dieser Patientin ist, was Sie gesagt haben.
Ob sie eventuell etwas im Urin hat.
Sie erwirten eine Proteinurie erwarten, haben Sie gesagt.
Gut, jetzt machen Sie eine Urindiagnostik.
Aber eins dürften wir nicht vergessen, im Blut müssten Sie bitte auch ausschließen,
ob sie ein Schilddrüselproblem hat.
Ja, das müssten Sie auch ausschließen.
Sie müssen gucken, ob das TSA-FT4 in Ordnung ist.
Ja, die Regeln sehen.
Ja, nicht vergessen, das dürfen Sie nicht vergessen.
Das müssten Sie ausschließen.
Jetzt haben Sie alles kontrolliert.
Das ist richtig.
Ist alles im Blut in Ordnung.
Bis auf folgende Werte.
Die Cholesterinwerte sind sehr erhöht.
Sie hat ein Gesamtcholesterin von 400.
Und die Triglyceride, den bei 250.
Sie hat einen Nierenwert, der ist bei 1,4.
Und das Harnstoff ist fast normal, ist nicht so erhöht.
Jetzt haben Sie Urin, also Zucker und so ist alles in Ordnung.
Sie hat keinen Infekt.
CHP ist in Ordnung, NTH-Gobel-NP ist in Ordnung,
Cholinesterase, Schilddrüsel ist alles in Ordnung.
Jetzt haben Sie ein Urin gemacht, in dem Urinsticks
ist ein Weiß dreimal positiv.
Sie hat keine Leute zütteln drin.
Keine Leute zütteln.
Aber Eiweiß, auch kein Blut.
Wenn Sie Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose jetzt einschränken,
was glauben Sie, was die Patienten haben könnte,
woran es liegen könnte?
Haben Sie den Blutbrut gemessen eigentlich?
Ich musste auch die Vitalparameter überprüfen.
In diesem Fall musste die Patientin
erhöhte Blutdruck erhören.
Sie hat ein Blutdruck von 140 zu 80.
140 zu 80.
Das ist ein bisschen erhöht, das ist grenzwertig.
Nefrotische Sandrum kommt in Betracht in diesem Fall.
Das ist eine sehr gute Verdacht.
Alles andere kann man mit dem Blut ausschließen,
mit dem EKG auch.
Das machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich würde gerne mit der Patientin,
bei der ich nicht mehr bin,
ich möchte, dass ich nicht mehr bin.
Ich möchte, dass ich nicht mehr bin.
Ich möchte, dass ich nicht mehr die Patientin kontrollieren und
mit denen dieses Auto auch限entooltas angesehen habe.
Und das starten Sie auch wieder zugleich vor.
Ja.
Sie möchten's insbesondere auch mit Ihrem Bildublissen machen.
Würden Sie diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Ja.
überwachen und eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen,
eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Ich würde diese Patientin Station auffnemen,
weil sie hat ...
erhöhte Risiko ...
mit dieser Blutwerte, erhöhte Kulissenwerte
und ja auch ... Beine Dämme.
Okay, gut.
Ist sie denn jetzt gefährdet?
Hat sie eine lebens- ...
gefährliche Erkrankung?
Wissen Sie das schon?
Nein, ich weiß noch nicht, aber alle können ...
eine Hemaise auch niedlende Sufizienz sein.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie ...
Sie haben gesehen, dass Kreatinienis bei 1,3, 1,4.
Der Harnstoff ist normal.
Ja.
Hat sie keine höhergraderen Niedernsuffizienzen?
Sie hat keine Entzündungszeichen.
Schilddrüse ist gut.
Zucker hat sie nicht.
Ist es gefährlich, diese Patienten wieder nach Hause zu lassen?
Kann man sie nach Hause entlassen und sagen,
der Hausarzt soll sich weiter kümmern um sie?
In diesem Fall muss diese Patientin
nähere ...
nähere beobachtet oder überwachtet werden.
Und ...
ja ...
diagnostisch ausdiagnostisch ...
musste mehr ...
diagnostische Methoden ...
durchgeführt werden.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Was würden Sie machen?
Bei einem ...
bei so einem Patienten gesagt, Sammelurin, 24-unsammelurin.
Kann man machen? Es gibt aber auch neuere Methoden.
Es gibt einen Spoturin.
Wissen Sie, was Spoturin ist?
Oder was würden Sie denn in dem Sammelunterurin bestimmen?
Was würden Sie nachschauen?
Jetzt haben Sie 24-unst lange Urin gesammelt.
Haben Sie 2-Liter Urin.
Was machen Sie damit?
Ja.
Leider kann ich mich nicht erinnern,
weil ich bin Anästhesistin und seit ...
Ja, okay.
Leider ...
... ist eine sehr unaufregende ...
... Reise seit 5-10 Jahren.
Ich habe nicht so einen Patienten behandelt.
Okay.
Ja, ich bin gut.
Okay, ja, ist gut.
Aber Sie haben ja schon gesagt, Sie würden Proteine warten.
Hm.
Das war ja schon richtig. Und Sie lagen auch richtig.
Denn im Urinsticks war Eiweiß 3-mal positiv.
Ja?
Sie hat eine zu hohe Eiweißausschaltung.
Sie können anstatt ...
... eine Sammelurins-Könse auch Spotturin machen.
Also eine kleine Menge Urinprobe.
Und was Sie dort messen können,
ist die Albumin creatininequotstient.
Hm.
Also Protein-Creatin-Ratio, heißt das.
Ne? Und wenn die erhöht ist,
haben Sie eine ...
... Proteinurie.
Das heißt, ein Nierenproblem.
Ne? Das ist verständlich.
Also Sie haben eine erhöhte ...
... eine erhöhte Ausscheidung von Proteinen.
So, damit haben Sie Ihre ...
... Verdachtdiagnose noch mal erhärtet,
dass Sie sagen, Sie hat ein Nierenproblem.
Ne?
Hm.
Gut. Jetzt haben Sie Ultraschall gemacht.
Im Ultraschall würden Sie was sehen.
Sie sind Anesthesystem.
Wahrscheinlich können Sie eine Niere nicht so gut schallen.
Denke ich mir mal.
Jetzt haben Sie den zum Internisten geschickt oder zum Radiologen.
Der sieht da nichts.
Niere ist unauffällig. Ultraschall ist komplett blande.
Ja? Aber Sie haben diesen einen Wert,
dass die Proteinausscheidung zu hoch ist.
Ne? Sie hat ein Nierenproblem.
Es ist aber ...
Es kann sein, dass die Glamorillopathy hat.
Deswegen können wir das nicht mit dem Ultraschall bestimmen.
Ganz genau. Sehr richtig.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Sie können Ihren Verdacht erhärten oder unterstützen
und sagen, Sie hat wahrscheinlich eine frottische Syndrome.
Hm.
Jetzt ist die nächste Frage ...
... von mir.
Was könnte der Grund für ein nefrottisches Syndrome sein?
Sie haben das gerade gut gesagt. Was kann es sein?
Es kann?
Eine Nummer 1?
Es kann wegen ...
Entschuldigung.
Wegen ...
Erhöhte kolästerin und triglyceridperte.
Es kann sein, dass ...
Angiopathy ...
... die Patienten Angiopathy ...
... in Glamorillen haben.
Hat.
Genau.
Es kann sein, dass die ...
... dass die Tubuli ...
... die Tubuli in den Nieren geschädigt sind.
Und dadurch nicht mehr gut ...
... filtrieren können.
Ja.
Okay. Wie kann man denn jetzt ...
... das ...
... feststellen?
Kann man ...
... Bio-C-Erznehmen?
Genau. Man muss ...
Man sollte eine Bio-C machen.
Ultraschallgeschöerte Bio-C-erz.
Kann man auch. Ganz genau.
Kann man auch wahrscheinlich ...
... CT gesteuert machen.
Aber ...
... Ultraschallgeschöerte geht normalerweise auch.
Ja, kann man machen.
Früher hat man das ja gemacht, als wir noch keinen CT hatten.
Hat man das Ultraschallgeschöerte ...
CT geschöert.
Gesteuert.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Gut.
Jetzt haben Sie letztendlich ...
... erkannt, dass Sie einen Lephortis-Syndrom hat.
Aufgrund einer Glomerole Nefrittis.
Welche Gefahren ...
... bestehen bei einem ...
... nefrottischen Syndrom ...
... zusätzlich, ...
... wenn Sie einen Proteinmangel hat.
Welche Gefahren ...
... was kann passieren?
Sie hat ja schon gesagt, ...
... dass Sie vor drei Monaten im Krankenhaus lag.
Wegen einer Grippe.
Mhm.
Woran liegt das?
Hatte sie einfach nur eine Grippe gehabt?
Oder kann es im Rahmen ...
... eines nefrottischen Symptoms ...
... auch zu einer erhöhten Infektanfälligkeit kommen?
Eine Infektanfälligkeit.
Dass sie also ...
... sehr schnell krank werden kann.
Ja.
Ja, post-pistochoxa-glomerole Nefrittis kann sein.
Ja, was ist das?
Ja, sie hat ja einfach ...
... wenig Protein im Körper.
Mhm.
Sie kann wenig Immunoglobuline produzieren.
Deswegen wird sie sehr krank.
Ja, oder öfters krank.
Immer wieder ...
... grippale Infekt oder so was.
Kann sie haben, muss sie nicht haben.
Es gibt aber noch eine Komplikation,
die diese Patienten oft auch haben.
Hat auch mit der Proteinausscheidung zu tun.
Das Antitrombin 3.
Das sorgt dafür, dass diese Patienten oft eine Trombose haben können.
Ja, dass sie also ...
... zur Trombose neigen können.
Mhm.
Gut.
Etwas haben wir aber vergessen in der Laborkontrolle,
die Seromelektrophoresis.
Da kann man sehen, wie viele Grobo-Line noch da sind.
Alpha, Beta, Gamma, Globulina.
Kann man dort gut nachschauen.
Wahrscheinlich wären die Alpha und Beta Globulina erhöht gewesen.
So, jetzt haben sie eine Biopsy gemacht,
und sie sehen, oder der Nephrologer oder der Internist hat ...
... Biopsy gemacht, und sie sehen, es ist eine ...
... irgendeine Glomerulinaephritis.
Wissen Sie, was eine Glomerulinaephritis ist?
Können Sie mir erklären, was eine Glomerulinaephritis ist?
Wissen Sie das?
Ja, wenn die ...
Ah.
Wenn die Selle ...
... oder ...
... an Art ...
... und die Fostreptococcyclic-Glomerulinaephritis ...
... wegen der Antiklamine ...
Wissen Sie, was sind denn die Glomerula? Was ist das?
Ja, ...
... Irina aus Scheidung ...
... erfolgt in Glomerula.
Ja?
Aha.
Und wenn die Gefesse in Glomerula geschädigt sind ...
... dann ...
... Irina aus Scheidung kann nicht ausreichend ...
... erfolgt.
Warten Sie mal.
Ja, oder andersrum.
Wenn die Glomerula belegt sind, wenn eine Membran ...
... durch eine Entzündung da ist,
dann kann nicht so viel zurückfiltriert werden in den Körper.
Und es wird mehr ausgeschieden.
Deswegen haben sie wenig Protein im Körper,
aber mehr draußen im Morin.
Parlostalminifarnost, okay.
Ja, das heißt, die Nieren arbeiten sehr richtig.
Mhm.
Es gibt verschiedene Arten von Glomerulinaephritiden.
Ja? Die möchte ich jetzt hier nicht eingehen.
Das sollte der Nierenart zu wissen.
Was würden Sie denn an Therapie bei der Patientin machen?
Minimum ...
Minimum der Nephritid ...
... mit Segmentanen ...
Diabetik, Pärtanzip ...
Glomerulinaephritid ...
... ist ...
... ein Ergner.
Hahaha.
Başka mit der ...
... Kostetasur.
Herkommen, ihr Helfen.
Wie können Sie nicht hören?
Können Sie mich hören?
Ja, jetzt.
Ja, genau.
Was für eine Therapie könnte man bei der Patientin machen?
Ja, ich muss ...
Oder jemand anderes vielleicht?
Vielleicht können Sie Ihre Kolleginnen fragen, ob Sie das wissen?
Immunspresivtherapie, Instruiztherapie ...
... äh ...
... wenn es ...
... post-Septikus-Glomerulinaephritid ist und wenn ...
... äh ...
... wegen dem Antikörper nach der Infektion ...
... äh ... die Grund ist,
... da Grund ist.
Ja.
Können wir diese Glomerulopothei mit Immunspresivtherapie behalten?
Mhm.
Ja.
Wir müssen ... äh ...
... in Blutdruck ...
... äh ...
... unter Kontrolle halten.
Sehr gut.
Mhm.
Darf die Patientin essen, was sie möchte?
Nein.
Sie ... äh ... der ... die Patientin muss ...
äh ... seis ... äh ... arm ...
... und ... äh ... protein ...
... ja, proteinreich ... äh ...
... proteinarm ...
... äh ... herrn ...
Mhm.
Was dürfen Sie nicht vergessen bei dieser Patientin?
Äh ... wir haben eben von Komplikationen gesprochen.
Mhm.
Es gibt ja auch eine Trombosekomplikation zum Beispiel.
Was ... was müssten Sie der Patientin für eine Therapie ...
... empfehlen?
Ja, wenn du um Trombos äh ...
Gefahr ist, du äh ...
... verweiten.
Wir müssen ... äh ... diese Patientin ... äh ...
... nicht als molekulär Heparin ... äh ...
verschreiben oder verabreichen.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Was aber passieren kann, wenn es jetzt eine sehr starke ...
... Albuminausscheidung gibt oder Proteinausscheidung ...
Mhm.
äh ... dann kann es sein, dass Heparin nicht wirkt.
Dann ...
Weil immer Antikombin 3 wirkt auf.
Das dürfen Sie nicht vergessen.
Was würden Sie stattdessen machen?
Ja, ich würde der Patientin Hymn und Albumin äh ...
... intravenös ...
... jeden Tag?
Äh ... ich muss die Blutwerte kontrollieren,
wenn es weniger als ein ...
... in Blut oder 1,5.
Können Sie auch statt Heparin was anderes geben?
Statt Heparin was anderes.
Was stärkeres vielleicht sogar.
Was Sie im Alltag nehmen kann.
Aspirin ...
Nein.
Das reicht nicht aus.
Aha.
Heparin ... Heparin ist genug stark nicht.
Ja, aber wenn das nicht mehr wirkt ...
... dann können Sie stattdessen geben auch.
Steptolitiktherapie, aber ...
... es gibt keine Hinweise auf Trombos.
Orale Antikoagulation können Sie auch geben.
Ja, Neue, No-Ax oder ...
No-Ax, genau, ne?
Ganz genau.
Es gibt verschiedene Sachen, die Sie ergeben können.
Jetzt haben Sie die Patienten, die hat ein Blutdruck von 140 zu 80 oder 90 Grad.
Wie würden Sie die therapieren, mit welchen Medikamenten?
Oder würden Sie gar nicht therapieren?
Ich möchte Sie ...
Würden Sie etwas geben?
Nein, ich mach ...
Äh ...
Das ist ganz fertig.
Weil die andere Praxis nicht kontrolliert.
Ja, das ist ganz fertig.
Ich in diesem Fall gebe keine Antipartanzen.
Aber ich muss sehr nähe ...
... die Patienten ...
... die Blutdruckwerte kontrollieren ...
Wie machen Sie das?
Sie haben ja nur eine Momentaufnahme von dem Blutdruck.
Ne?
Sie haben einmal bei sich in der Ambulanz ein Blutdruck gemessen.
M-hm.
Er ist 140 zu 80 gewesen.
Was machen Sie, wenn Sie die Patienten nicht dazu näher aufnehmen?
Eine?
Ich kann die Patienten an der Munition anschließen.
Ja.
Mussten Sie an den Munitor unbedingt?
Nein.
Nein, ich kann die Patienten auch ...
äh ...
Langzeit ...
Blutdruckmessung.
Genau. Können Sie eine Frage machen?
Dann sehen Sie den Verlauf.
Wenn der jetzt mal grenzwertig ist,
kann man überlegen, ob man mit einem Medikament einsteigt.
M-hm.
Welches Medikament würden Sie machen,
wenn Sie ansteigen müssten?
Welche Wirkstoff?
Oder welche ...
ja, welchen ...
ja, welches Medikament?
Ja, ich weiß nicht in diesem Fall,
ob Sie AC-Hemmer wirken können.
Können Sie wirken?
Können Sie probieren?
Oder auch den Isatane, ne?
Die ...
M-hm.
ARB.
Wenn Sie auch probieren, ganz genau.
Eine Sache müssen Sie trotzdem noch kontrollieren
oder reduzieren.
Sie hat die erhöhte Cholesterinwerte gehabt, ne?
Gesamtcholesterin von 400.
Wie würden Sie das therapieren?
Ich muss die erhöhte Fettswarte mit ...
äh ...
niedrigen ...
M-hm.
Niedrigen.
Genau.
Sehr gut. Ja.
Okay.
Gut, das haben Sie eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Ähm ...
Was machen wir denn jetzt mit den Odemen?
Mit den Odemen, ja.
Äh ...
Was da entlastet, Tablete können in diesem Fall hier fresh sein.
Äh, Hydrochlorotheasit.
Äh, kommen in diesem Fall ...
zum Einsatz.
Was kennen Sie noch?
Äh, Hydrochlorotheasit.
Oder ansonsten ...
Gibt's auch was anderes, was Sie machen können?
Äh, oder Sipranolakton.
Sipranolakton.
Zum Beispiel.
Äh, oder ...
Potassium ...
äh ...
Kalium ...
Potassiumtutucidiurethicanastendraum.
Das ist Sipranolakton.
Ja.
Und Äploredo, zum Beispiel.
Aber auch normal können Sie wahrscheinlich auch normale Diarrheutiktherapie machen.
Thorosameth, Phrosameth zum Beispiel können Sie probieren.
Mhm.
Gut.
Jetzt haben Sie die Patienten entlassen.
Sie ist nach Hause. Was empfehlen Sie der Patienten denn?
Äh, was Sie auf jeden Fall ...
machen sollte in Zukunft.
An welchen Arzt sollte Sie sich anbinden?
Äh ...
Ja, Sie muss sich äh ...
regelmäßig kontrollieren lassen.
Äh, bei der Äh ...
Nephrologen ...
Genau.
Das übt sich ganz gut an.
Gut. Haben Sie Fragen?
Haben Sie Fragen noch?
Äh ...
Ich würde auch sagen, dass ...
äh ... bei der Ernährung ...
äh ... Sie muss eh ihre Ernährungsgewohnheiten wieder umstellen.
Genau.
Ja.
Sie sollte gucken, dass sie ...
ausgewogene Militärane Diät macht, auch wenn sie ...
eigentlich nicht ...
adipöses, ne? Sie ist schlank.
Aha.
Sie ist schlank, aber dadurch, dass sie einen ...
Nieren-Schaden hat, muss sie gucken, wie sie sich ernährt.
Das ist schon sehr wichtig.
Sie muss sie fit arme, proteinarme, umsassarme ...
ernehmen.
Genau so machen. Ganz genau.
Bleibt das ein Leben lang jetzt so,
oder geht das auch manchmal wieder zurück?
Hier ist es ein erforderlicher Syndrome.
Muss sie das ein Leben lang,
so machen oder kann es sein,
dass das irgendwann wieder besser wird?
Ja, es wird besser.
Es ist eine behandbare Krankheit.
Äh ... aber ...
äh ... für ihre Gesundheit ...
äh ... muss sie ...
sie hat aber irgendwie eine Neigung.
Deswegen ... äh ...
muss sie immer unter Kontrolle bleiben.
Ja.
Genau.
Ja, sehr gut.
War etwas ...
ungewöhnlich, glaube ich.
Wie wir das Thema schon mal gehabt,
ist das schon mal gefragt worden hier?
Für mich, es war schon erst mal.
Okay.
Meine Allekennnisse ...
aus meiner ...
medizinische Vergüttelte, oder ...
ja, diese ...
Ja, okay. Aber ...
... innere Medizinerthema ...
Man denkt ja oft an Herzinsuffizienz,
oder Trombose oder so was,
aber man muss halt immer auch ...
äh ... das ist eine fröhliche Syndrome.
Im Kopf behalten, ne?
Können auch junge Patienten sein,
nicht immer die älteren Patienten.
Und deswegen muss man das immer ...
im Hinterkopf haben und dran denken.
Ja.
Urindiagnostik ist ganz wichtig in diesem Fall.
Ne?
Es war aber sehr gut.
Ich habe viel gelernt. Danke.
Ja? Okay.
Wir haben einen sehr detaillierten
und informativen Unterricht gegeben.
Äh ... unser Wissen wurde aufgerichtet.
Ich habe jetzt sehr genossen.
Äh ... vielen Dank.
Alles klar. Ich danke euch.
Ich wünsche euch viel Erfolg.
Das war ein Gehirnsturm.
Es war sehr gut.
Gehirnsturm war sehr gut.
Hat viel Spaß gemacht.
Andererseits, es war sehr gut. Danke.
Nicht Gehirnstürm, Brainstormin.
Brainstürm, ja.
Gehirnstürm ist ...
Nicht so.
Okay.